fresh off that dust emporia episode
i think i realized i i've just i've
turned into too much of a dustin
fan to maybe talk with him sometimes i'm
just such a
you know i'm just a fan of so much of
who he is as a person
and uh and as a friend he's been a good
friend to me and um
you know we've kind of we've developed a
friendship over the years some and
i'm not going to say we're best friends
or nothing like that do because you know
uh
i'm an adult and we don't really have
best friends at this age but um
but he you know obviously i'm a fan
undeniably
and i'm just excited for him and it was
just
i was just so excited to have him on and
just like you know
i was just grateful that he gave me that
time this guy's about to this man's in
abu dhabi
you man this man is in the desert baby
he's out there about to sand wrestling
that sand
casa
he's about to castle roll you feel me
um and i just you know he's got to get
counter to the ground i think but well
you know and i want to sit there and
sell it but i don't know
i don't know something bit
some bad [ __ ] over there the uh
nashville mma put me into a damn figure
9 last week
so what you know i can't even answer the
phone in one of my one of my hands is
all
stagnant because of whatever she did to
me damn hexed me
so i you know i'm all i can do is just
we cheer
and about win or lose the man's a
champion and i was just honored to be in
his presence
that's honestly how i feel i'm just
sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
blown